there is no easy road to what you want
it's a long road you got a lot of people
want to be a doctor some people don't
want to go to school for eight years
right but the ones that go to school for
eight years end up being some of the
best doctors ever and that's what i
learned at a young age no matter what
you can't escape work you can't
the only way to escape work is easy
right just quit flipping money there is
a world for that but that world nine
times out of ten ends bad you're not
gonna escape work
you're not and that's what i realized so
instead of trying to escape it i address
it from the standpoint of putting 110
into it in any and everything i do
anything there is no half ass